and today I prepared to show you a game
that I played last Wednesday at the u.s.
chess league I'm playing for the st.
Louis team Archbishop's and - currently
we are tied for first in a Western
Division and tomorrow we're going to
have a big match week 10 and if we win
we will win the division and go to
playoffs with the first place so thank
you yeah it's a very very important
match tomorrow so if you have time you
can watch you can comment a club watch
here in person and cheer for the team or
you can just do it at home on ICC you
can support the local team so this game
I'm playing against international
masters mark Ginsburg II 46 name of the
opening yes French defense correct very
good excellent French defense now what
are the four options now they can try to
do here in French defense where are the
four options you know tell me all the
main four options for white years who
can do it first one correct they are
hard and do not you
93 is called classical and that's what
mr. Ginsberg is doing 93 classical he's
playing the classical setup so what do
you play I'm playing in this game and
trying to create some winning chances
here I didn't want to just try to
equalize so I wanted to play something a
little sharper here so I decided to
steer away from my normal play D take c4
or Knight f6 and play the Bishop g4 here
Bishop before here and what's the name
of this variation
it's a French defense classical but now
Bishop before it's a different one what
is it called here been over then over
excellent yes so now here white should
play e5 if he doesn't play a5 he cannot
fight for advantage so he has to play e5
it's necessary okay but he didn't do it
okay he didn't want to go for the sharp
dia reticle lines with c5 and takes
takes Queen g4 97 queen 97 queen g4 this
is the way that white should play for
advantage okay so but he didn't do that
my opponent he decided to play something
rare night ge7 but when you play a rare
alliance against short continuation then
normally you're not going to have an
advantage okay so now here's what should
I try to do sheesh from here on I want
you to take control and find all the
moves that I played when he resigned
this wasn't a very long game only 31
moves or maybe even less actually what
did I play here absolutely a polaron
gives you a pawn in the opening early
stages in the game you look at it there
is no big reason for you not to take it
so you accept that now he goes a3
attacking a bishop now Bishop is getting
challenged here I have two options
either retreat or capture what do you
think I should do here I'm playing for a
win in this game remember I am playing
trying to play for a win here trying to
play as sharp as possible so black 2
here decision needed here huh but in
that case he takes your central pawn
then yes but then he get chased around
again no and then then he takes such we
don't want to move the bishop too many
times like that that's not going to be
very very good so what do we do here huh
Bishop takes c3 correct decision he
takes Knights if you don't play a five
here Danny very dangerous the five you
know you're behind in development
playing a five you will play f3 break
the center and then he will have two
sharp pair of bishops okay so this this
could actually turn out to be very
dangerous for you look at this this guy
comes in Bishop comes in castle very
sharp you behind in development too
risky play it safe but again you have to
put pressure okay now what's the move
here we gotta try to get development
okay we got to catch up on development
here how
Knight f3 no no you're playing for Black
Knight f6 you're gonna get P in the
Bishop g5 that's going to be temporarily
okay temporarily you got to do something
better than that
you don't want to get pinned okay
so what is my idea here to try to put
pressure here to try to play for
advantage not easy but I had to do this
otherwise I will just have an equal game
and it's not going to be a not easy
going to be to try to get winning
chances against a you know strong
international masters yes excellent good
job
96 excellent thinking developing a
knight and immediately questioning his
pawn what is he going to do he's got two
options but if it was Bishop D then it's
passive then we can try to consider even
playing Knight f6 because then he cannot
play the bishop away so we should be
fired that's what he played don't rush
thinking thinking this is very important
game you cannot rush Bishop d7 he takes
you up on 94 and then it's not so clear
you know you still have to follow the
rules guys development right remember he
is trying to take your knight and damage
your structure are you gonna let him do
that
Dani excellent thinking yes 97 if he
takes you take back with a knight okay
excellent
just simple development here he made a
mistake and looks like this was his
chance to take the pawn he didn't do it
I think he didn't do this because he
didn't like the fact that I will Castle
and then his pawn is hanging and it's
not so clear what is he going to do now
because it's like if it goes here I even
have like Queen d5 which would be kind
of unpleasant everything is hanging and
this g2 is weak okay
so anyway he should have done this he
didn't do it I also have a maybe a good
position after a six questioning the
Bishop Bishop was here I go p5 then I
take the d4 pawn if it takes here 90s
then take this guy okay alright so my
opponent played sorry castles now now
what are you going to do he just
canceled you still cannot take that take
the pawn on d4 because you're no you
know you're pinned Castle just Castle
keep it safe remember that's your step
number three castle keep it safe now now
you want to take this pawn already see
he had the chance he had an opportunity
to take but he didn't take it and now
he's not going to have a chance anymore
because he has to go Bishop e3 okay
because bish clear now strong move
needed here
strong move needed here excellent
fi protecting the night and now 13
two-player for in some point excellent
this is the moment to do it see I had to
get development before I think about
protecting upon don't be thinking o be
greedy little bit oh I want upon I got a
protecting no matter what C I was ready
to give it back to him to catch up on
development and he should have taken
that pawn because now he's never going
to get that pump back because now I'm
going to try to hang on to that pawn as
much as possible if he plays f3 what's
the strong continuation now f4 perfect
attacking the bishop he moves away look
at that look at the protected past pawn
only three now next one we picking up
the pawn on d4 as well so I think right
around here you realize that things went
wrong so it was 92 I'm better but still
if you don't play precisely it's not
going to be easy to win a position like
this because don't forget he has a small
compensation because he still has the
pair of the bishops now I would like you
to establish the grip you know the
control for your knight on d5 here how
you going to establish that outpost for
your knight here's what you need to do
first to do that
well possible a place to place United
great 2005 very good thinking a six if
it takes I'll be gladly taking him back
and he doesn't have the two bishops
anymore so he goes Bishop play for and
now push it now he goes here
and now what you gonna do outpost posted
the right
that's an outpost that he cannot move
you from the pond anymore right
very strong now he please see for
attacking your night I take he takes and
now what you going to do from now on
that's an interesting computer
suggestion actually I'm not sure if it's
better than what I did but that computer
suggested this also [ __ ] paid too
yeah but I don't want to keep moving the
knife that much I just wanna 94 is a
possibility yeah I think it's possible
yeah whitest black is better yeah
Bishop here it's an idea yeah so I just
put this guy here first when you put a
knight on a square like this this cannot
be a bad move okay
it cannot be a bit more when you cement
a knight like that in the middle of the
board okay I remember that just so he
played c4 took bishop takes and now what
to do who is going to power I don't want
to give you hints now because if I give
you hints it makes it much easier now
now from here man I want you to play
like a grandmaster for the rest of the
game very precisely okay let's see let's
Dinkley here let's think a little bit
what is the correct move here look at
the position try to see which piece
could be improved here huh which piece
you can improve a little bit and you
know he wants to go look see one he
wants to put pressure on that see file
as well so he's trying to do things -
okay you ready sure a five a little bit
loosen a little bit loosening look see
one at the see five six nine thinking a
little bit could be little bit loosening
think you have an unprotected piece here
and that unprotected piece can be
improved here night on the rim is damn
lonely in them right don't put a night
on the rim because it's going to get dim
so better
bravo Bravo correct decision look at
this when you have Knights they want to
be like this protecting each other okay
because when they're doing this they're
very very strong if a capture occurs you
go ninety-five centralizing the pieces
Knights they like to be like this
protecting each other now he goes Queen
d2 now another good move needed here I
believe you need to catch up on your
development a little bit and here the
good thing the beauty of it you make a
move and you threatening something that
means he has to react that gives you
additional time to develop your more
pieces so what is the mood that is going
to develop and threaten something
develop and threaten something how about
we increase the threat level and we make
a real threat now developing movement
threatening something else Bravo again
very strong 26 developing and
threatening to play f4 trapping that
Bishop what do you think of that idea to
trap it now if he plays Knight f4 which
looks very tempting who can tell me why
is this move a blunder why is this move
losing huh absolutely then a correct
attacking the knight Knight moves away F
for winning the bishop and if it takes
how you're going to capture with a epon
keep on attacking the bishop if Bishop
takes on g5 we take it C tempos remember
chess it's all about temples he moves
away the bishop then thank you for the
bishop you see how that works when you
put your pieces on a good squares good
things going to happen to you so it's
all about putting your pieces on good
squares so now he's forced to play the
g3 move I know he doesn't want to play
this but he's forced to now back to your
idea that was good now find a better
version of that move now your idea
bishop
assembly should beef I was good but now
find a better and more active version of
it we want to get rid of the bishops
right French defense what's the biggest
problem in French defense who knows that
when you have a chance what do you do
excellent
better version of that better better
version of that better version you have
of that you have a point you have a
point bit too long but you have a point
yes be too long something better I'd
rather see those bishops coming off the
board because then I will capitalize on
the weaknesses of the light squares how
are we going to do that
that's that was suggested already yeah
that was already suggested but better
same idea but better version of it okay
same idea better better but what better
version from you
opponent has to bishops when opponent
has advantage of two bishops you want to
exchange one get rid of one okay that's
what you want to do why do you want to
take that bishop the bishop is stuck
there you have a superior knight on d5
let's do that later when we have
complete the development okay you can
take that the bishop is not going
anywhere I mean he this is you know very
good piece so don't worry about that
bishop right now let's try to get our
development somebody even suggested this
move earlier of course but now it's time
for t5 okay now it's time for a5
excellent Bravo excellent thinking the
point of this movie is of course now my
opponent went here now I go Bishop a6 b3
now this is a really tough moment here
this is a challenge okay challenge think
now because now when you have the nights
like this beautifully protecting each
other sometimes they are not as
effective because one is taking a space
of the other one and the one behind is
kind of crumble up you just just
defending okay so now which idea comes
into place which idea that comes into
place no did you listen the question
we're talking about Knights Knights are
stepping on each other squares okay
which idea now comes into play
finally hi finally yes this is the
moment you do it okay this is called
proper chess
look at the super look at the superior
bishop you have here so superior you
know look picking away four rupee a
double-up the rooks I mean it plays by
itself this position you know just go
here you go here double up the rooks I
mean it's not difficult you just double
up beautiful bishop you have now plant
the bishop here if you want to okay so
b3 now we take if it takes to the queen
then you go 95 gaining additional tempos
if it takes pawn takes back on doubling
those doubled pawns okay so heat it back
with this now important sequence here
think now you want to put some pressure
on that B file right put some pressure
on the B file now which rook I'm sorry
what is the rook doing here action is
where now action is focus we're actually
focused on which side of the board now
absolutely look at that action is here
well nothing in my attack right now
we're talking about you know getting the
advantage here positional advantage
there okay now he goes Knight therefore
and now what are you gonna do he's
starting to take your pawn here he
cannot take with the rook because this
pawn is weak here so he has to take back
with a pawn and if he takes back with a
pawn what do we do
that beef absolutely but then this pawn
is always hanging you know queen is
attacking directly and I want to secure
a square you know I want to secure a
strong square for my outpost for my rook
here so the movies
absolutely for yes ready to go rugby
tree now he goes look c3 I bet he didn't
expect me to play this move here I bet
you he didn't think of this move he
thought he is getting some kind of
control maybe but now strong move comes
in here then you look at my rooks what
side of the board you think we should
play here pawn g5 e values shifting the
action to other side of the board I
think we have to focus where we are
strong right now right we building up
here right and what was the purpose of
the move a4 to secure which square
absolutely and remember when you were
ahead you never afraid to trade and I
have an extra pawn right extra pawn your
head you never afraid to trade now he
takes because I will double up Queen B 2
attacking my pawn rook b8 rook c1 this
is a tough move to find because looks
like suddenly now might be 3 power might
be a little bit weak and it's in a
garage c3 and put pressure on this but
here I spend some time I went deep into
thoughts here and came up with a strong
continuation I have a strong asset now
on top of having the extra part strong
asset is the b3 pawn here so what can
you do here
but where that's a logical thinking that
is a very logical thinking but where
excellent thinking 96 but any place he
didn't play this move but do you have a
solution for this night on the rim it's
not ideal yeah yes I'm better after 95 I
agree I am better I agree with you but
if I had a chance to play this move it
would have been really even more
spectacular game rather G rather than
positionally Knight takes correct look
at that now treating to check here so he
has to take check now he goes here now
don't rush here one inaccurate move and
you not winning this game one in
accuracy yes one in accuracy and you're
not winning this game you think why did
I say that one I won in accuracy you
blew way to win you have to remember
that okay
that's why I don't blew the winning
position here okay
this is winning for you but you need to
find a neat move here
you have a passed pawn what do you do
with it push it past pond cement to be
pushed now he goes here's chicka and now
what's the winning move pusher pusher
and going in okay excellent
it's still winning g5f for this winning
- so this is crushing and if you go see
this is funny I just go push here and
let's say he attacks me I push again I
did all this so just to get his knife
from here to there so then I can do
whose idea
yeah idea and we push here we push see
tonight is now ineffective ineffective
okay and then you Quinn
excellent well that didn't happen
unfortunately very unfortunately that
didn't happen because I was looking
forward to that tactical sequence so he
played see if I have attacking my queen
you still have to be precise here it's
not over yet now where do you go with
the Queen where do you go with the Queen
here
well guys we don't need to think too
hard on this one it's pretty obvious the
next move what is it
okay I guess not so obvious you're 6 -
weak so you can just go away from it sir
then you're very good now if it was red
rook city then who are we going to do
absolutely same idea is back we're back
in action with this so he goes here now
takes away the a5 squared from the night
and now he wants to get active with you
know Quincy for rook p1 he wants to put
some pressure on me you know now what
are you going to do you gotta find this
move then his next two moves were very
important to win the game okay because
and also win effectively you know
without dragging the game you know to
several moves unnecessarily yes
is my weight my form that plane is 95
Omega 97 97 absolutely right away now
you're aiming to go here now he played
Quincy 4 in expectation that I have to
defend this or play 95 then he takes
that's what he was hoping for ok or king
f7 I go defend but now move that he
probably didn't expect move that is very
powerful and will give me the winning
position now after this point we can
call it winning for black but you must
calculate you can't just play this move
you have to have some calculations did
you calculate everything Danny
Bravo Wow very very strong calculation
it's it's even even even simpler okay
let's finish this line then we'll go
with that then takes right takes Bravo
Bravo
look at that see the b-pawn Queen so he
took back with the knight quintics was
asked now we take take and now what we
do and then you could be 293 and victory
is assured got it
excellent so after this my opponent went
here now your three moves away from
victory here is lined in a position that
it was completely hopeless I mean he he
could have played a few more moves but
he just realized it's just lost so
what's the idea here
Bravo put it out post attack it now keep
going
keep working that's enough dot but do
you have something simpler than that
so what is the spawn ceiling they're
here for hot spawns meant to be pushed
that's one now what you do and he
resigned because if he takes I take
sorry he pushes you don't go back then e
you go in now he pushes thank you you go
here he pushes here core and you take
this any questions about this game
excellent
now we're going to do the over review of
the game and we're going to see how well
the students here remember this ok
everybody should be participating so I
will I will call you on this ok ok we
are ready to start and it's a pretty
simply clear game I think so you should
remember it so we're going to start from
here
you play the black moves which opening
is this everyone French defense
which line is it playing classical which
should respond did I play what is it
called the name of this line the black
chooses then over then over win over win
over yes very good
that's fine we got it we got it back to
you 92 he didn't play the main line took
upon a tree what do you do
pop pop okay okay back to you
I know still you can choose you can
answer it yeah we should be fine
continue now he wants to take your night
and damage your pawn structure are you
gonna let him do that
then then what are you gonna do to avoid
that
night-night go where
there he go excellent hint yes
castles he should have taken it castles
now what are we gonna do now Castle
don't you eat castled Bishop III at five
now he played night II - and now you
want to establish that outpost remembers
how now continue
it's him but he's put a night
where
d5 excellent yes c4 we take he takes now
next cement tonight remember the nights
they like to protect each other
excellent now he goes here developing
move and threatening move not yet not
yet not yet remember you say this move
you forgot you you suggested this move
what's the move here develop and
threaten develop and threaten yes Queen
d6 remember you say that yeah excellent
g3 now back to you Denny biggest problem
in the French defense when you have a
chance what do you do get rid of it
[ __ ] pay six
he played b3 and now remember what the
Knights are sitting on each other now
what you're supposed to do
very nice thinking and now the next move
is we got to get our look into the game
look on f8 right rook f b8 excellent
Knight f4 next
very good thinkin now when you play a
four what do you do what was the purpose
of it now he's threatening to go tucks
it now you gotta get your knight in
Denny Knight wants to be a participant
excellent
White's doing this wonder some glitch
here okay
c5 attacking the Queen now where is the
Queen be long
excellent
Roxy three and now
94 again so here to Delta plate queen c3
and now we have to maneuver it back the
knight very good memory yes 97 very nice
Quincy four and now the tricky moment
here where he attacked on me thinking
I'm going to crumble up and defend but
instead I calculated deeper and try to
push him back immediately because the
night only four is the piece that is
holding his position together
what is the move here rava g5 if he
takes if he takes b2 Knight c3 wins
if 96 then this was a hard move to find
25 because this was forcing the
liquidation he takes night X okay so he
goes Knight to e2 now Knight belongs
where the knight 27 belongs on d5
excellent King f2 and now push the pan
and Queen B five forces the resignation
he resigned because if it takes
I take he goes here rupee three see when
you have position is dominating then
unit time
excellent job everyone excellent job
very good thinking okay at the end of
the lecture I'll have one special study
for you to solve not very difficult okay
this is PI troitskiy okay throw each key
study okay for you I promise it's not
very hard like some of the other ones
I did sorry white to play and win I tell
you this if the F pawn wasn't there for
black he could make a draw easily if he
can somehow get his Bishop in without me
getting mated this is a draw but you
have to choose this you use this
opportunity here okay
to find a way to win em so very special
play needed here then you have to
remember that maneuvering your night
okay maneuverability of your knight is
important here
try to suggest the whole thing when you
raise your hand not just the first few
moves
denne
excellent see the point is he cannot go
here because of the mate so has to go
here now correct thinking yes correct
Inc and he can go here still mates he
goes here and now you just got to
control that g8 square okay with
something yes yeah
c6 or d7 which one either one works
let's assume we go here okay assume you
cannot go away we take the bishop people
say now take away the square now
immediately immediately yeah
King cannot go anywhere he goes here a
what we call this checkmate okay you
could have you could have also done it
this way by the way and 9f8 this way you
have a mate as well here got it yeah
a very special idea starting with King
h6 here its mate say has to go King g8
night f3 maneuver the knight and 96 or
97 both wins leads to mate or you can
start with 97 here and wait okay very
good everyone thank you for attending
the class tonight and to look forward
seeing you all on Thursday evening